Welcome to Cloud Minute
Today I'm going to show you how to enable and disable APIs
in the Google Cloud Platform
I'm working on a new project and when I run
and when I run
'gcloud compute instances list'
I get an error saying that access is not configured.
If you run into this
it just means you haven't enabled that API for your project.
Google Cloud Platform requires you to enable APIs
so that you're only using the products you want to use.
From the Developers Console click APIs & auth
and then click APIs
Now you need to select the API you want to enable.
If it isn't listed on this first page
you can search for it using the search box.
Once you find the API you want
click on the name and then click enable API
Once it finished enabling
I can use the gcloud compute functions from the command line
If you want to see what APIs are enabled for your project
click APIs, Enabled APIs and that will show you a list
of the APIs currently enabled for your project.
If you want to disable an API
you can do so from here or you can do
so from the APIs page where you enabled it
I hope you found this helpful.